from joining the mighty Avengers to
falling into Wonderland there's a whole
lot that Cassie Lang also known as
stature has done and seen in the Marvel
Comics universe
many Marvel moviegoers learned about
Cassie Lang in the first Ant-Man film in
which her father Scott had to rescue her
from the villainous yellow jacket
[Music]
casual comic fans may also know that
Cassie's Alter Ego stature is a
relatively modern creation of Marvel
Comics debuting in 2005's Young Avengers
number six despite what you might think
though Cassie herself is no newcomer she
made her first appearance all the way
back in 1979's Marvel Premiere number
47. in the issue Cassie Lang makes her
debut alongside her father Scott who
makes his own first appearance as the
second Ant-Man unlike the first Ant-Man
film in which Scott steals the ant-man's
suit because he can't hold down a job
Comics Ant-Man turns to a life of crime
to try to make money to fix Cassie's
heart effect when he learns that the
only Doctor Who can save her is being
held hostage by Darren cross he steals
Henry pym's old super suit to save Dr
Sondheim and cure his daughter's ailment
after Lang becomes the new Ant-Man
full-time he inadvertently leaves Cassie
with superpowers of her own it's later
discovered that Khan's instant exposure
to the Pim particles that power the
ant-man's suit gives Cassie her father's
ability to change in size without the
need for any special equipment
Ant-Man himself has gone by a few
different names and so too has Cassie
Lang
stature is just one of a few superhero
names that she's adopted over the years
she was briefly nicknamed ant girl after
her father too however Cassie also has
another Super identity Stinger the first
version of stinger doesn't exist in the
main Marvel Universe Earth 616 even long
time readers may not remember that
Cassie's Stinger Persona has its own
origins in the mc2 Universe Earth 982 as
seen in the pages of a next number one
there she fights as a member of a future
offshoot Avengers team more than a
decade after that appearance Cassie Lang
would officially take the name stinger
in the main Marvel Universe this occurs
after an incident in which she is
kidnapped by Darren cross and has her
heart stolen leaving her without her
powers desperate to regain them Cassie
resorts to Extreme Measures making a
deal with the villainous power broker
for a suit that will restore her
shrinking Powers as Stinger she Dons her
purple gems suit and classic Ant-Man
helmet giving Cassie the iconic wasp
look complete with bug-like wings
even superheroes need best friends and
Comics history has given us plenty of
Buddy pairings from Superman and Batman
to Spider-Man and the Human Torch Cassie
Lang has her own superhero bestie
Hawkeye her teammate and the leader of
the Young Avengers we're not talking
about Clint Barton but his Protege the
teenaged Kate Bishop who took up the
name and title of the avenging archer in
the mid-2000s while Lang and Bishop have
had romances with different superhero
teammates over the years they always
took solace in each other's friendship
as BFFs more than just superhero
colleagues Kate and Cassie support each
other through good times and bad when
Cassie has her powers taken away it's
Kate who comes to her side it's a
reminder that she doesn't need
superpowers to be special or to be a
hero something she can personally attest
to as the non-powered Hawkeye being hero
isn't just for people who can fly or
shoot lasers out of their hands it's for
anyone given the pair's history in the
comics it's fair to speculate that their
friend friendship could find its way to
live action now that both are heroes in
the MCU
those familiar with Cassie Lang's
stature probably know that she was one
of the earliest members of The Young
Avengers first appearing in the
mid-2000s the group has become one of
the most popular teams of young heroes
in Marvel Comics much more than a mere
collection of Sidekicks however the
Young Avengers aren't the only team that
Cassie Lang has been a part of during
her colorful history as a hero during
Marvel's Civil War storyline stature is
rescued by the resistance and fights on
Captain America's Secret Avengers team
however she's also one of the earliest
members to defect quitting the team in
Civil War number four after becoming
disillusioned at the prospect of
fighting other Heroes when Shield teams
up with Iron Man to establish officially
sanctioned superhero groups for every
state stature is one of their first
recruits later in the mighty Avengers
number 21 the reappearance of the
Scarlet Witch the Spurs stature and the
newly reborn Vision to join the
reassembled Mighty Avengers team
although it's later revealed that the
person they thought was Wanda maximoff
was actually Loki in disguise
in Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania
Cassie Lang and her father square off
against the most diabolical villain the
MCU has ever produced King the Conqueror
as odd as it may sound the teenaged
Cassie Lang was actually romantically
involved with Kang for a time in the
comics well sort of this connection
comes from Cassie's time with the Young
Avengers where one of her teammates was
a new character known as iron lad while
initially introduced as a mystery hero
who some speculated might be related to
Iron Man it is eventually revealed that
he is actually a time-displaced younger
version of the temporal despot Kang
after a story in Young Avengers number
five in which the youthful iron lad
kills Kang a future version of himself
he is forced to return to his proper
place in the time stream before he does
he gives Cassie a kiss and programs his
armor to become a new version of the
former Avengers hero vision and gives it
both his and the vision's memories
eventually this new somewhat more naive
and vaguely younger looking version of
The Vision begins a new romance with
stature rekindled thanks to his memories
of being iron lad
King the Conqueror wasn't the only
Marvel super villain that Cassie Lang
had eyes for it seems her attraction to
enemies of the Avengers is something of
a pattern however like her relationship
with iron lad who wasn't quite Kang her
love for another one of Marvel's evil
tyrants isn't quite what it seems in
this case she was smitten with Kristoff
Bernard the young ward of Dr Doom who
would eventually take up the mantle of
the lot Varian dictator himself you'd be
forgiven if that name doesn't ring any
bells as many of Bernard's appearances
were in the 80s and 90s when he was
still a child initially he comes into
Doom's care after his parents are killed
in a violent revolution after the real
Doom is apparently killed Bernard is
brainwashed by doombots in Fantastic
Four number 278 leading him to believe
that he is Dr Doom after being defeated
by The Fantastic Four the team takes the
child to live with them and that's where
he meets the young Cassie Lang a
childhood Crush soon develops between
them it's hardly a True Romance but an
alternate future offers a glimpse of
what their relationship could have been
in the mc2 Universe Bernard now a heroic
Doctor Doom and Cassie have an adult
romance in the pages of fantastic five
number five where they do some pretty
passionate lip locking
Cassie Lang doesn't seem to have many
long-time enemies or rivals in the first
two Ant-Man movies except maybe agent Wu
why can't you just leave my daddy alone
in the comics though her long history
has left her with bad blood for several
major characters there's one notable
bitter enemy of hers that might surprise
you Wanda maximoff better known as the
Scarlet Witch while the two haven't met
on screen yet they were well acquainted
in the Marvel Comics continuity Wanda
was a longtime co-worker of Cassie's
father before she sparked a few
company-wide events in the 1998 issue of
the Avengers that left Cassie holding a
serious Grudge in Avengers number 500 a
hero known as Jack of Hearts who had
been dead for some time returns
unexpectedly he kills Scott Lang in a
scheme orchestrated by Wanda who has
begun to lose her grip on reality While
others are able to forgive Wanda as she
is revealed to have been mind controlled
Cassie never does
as stature Cassie Lang has the power to
grow to tremendous size much like her
father this gives her the ability to
take on some of the strongest villains
around and even some fellow Heroes
during the Civil War storyline however
even after the Civil War ends and
stature joins the 50 state initiative
she has one last Hero on hero fight when
she clashes with her father's Ant-Man
replacement Erica Grady this happens at
Camp Hammond when the initiative is
training new recruits including stature
in Avengers the initiative number eight
O'Grady begins mocking the previous
Ant-Man to impress Taskmaster pushing
Cassie over the edge growing to giant
size she calls out her father's
replacement and he supersizes himself
unwilling to back down what follows is a
brutal hand-to-hand fight between
skyscraper-sized Heroes unfortunately
the more experienced O'Grady comes out
on top years later Cassie gets a kind of
Revenge and Ant-Man and number three
there black ant a villainous life model
decoy posing as Eric O'Grady briefly
takes her hostage in the ensuing fight
black ant is no match for Cassie who
grows to a massive size and squishes him
with the palm of her hand
after Scott Lang is killed through the
machinations of the Scarlet Witch during
The Avengers disassembled storyline
Cassie is inconsolable though she would
eventually find Solas and family with
the Young Avengers in the ensuing years
she never lets go of the bitterness she
feels after the death of her father
however Cassie gets a second chance with
the help of iron lad who takes her and a
group of Avengers back through time to
try and restore Wanda maximoff to her
old self finding themselves back in the
past before the death of her father
Cassie is compelled to whisk him away
into the future before he can meet an
untimely demise this leaves the Avengers
of the past to believe that Scott has
been killed by Jack of Hearts as a
result history remains unchanged but
Scott returns to the land of the living
in the present day where he and Cassie
get another chance to be a family in
some ways this storyline shares
similarities to Cassie and Scott's
relationship in the MCU where Scott
reunites with his older more mature
daughter after returning from five years
in the quantum Realm
[Music]
sandwiched between massive crossovers
House of M and Avengers vs X-Men
Avengers The Children's Crusade sees the
resurrection of Scott Lang lead almost
directly to Cassie's own demise after
the time traveling adventure to restore
a Scarlet Witch momentary Ally Dr Doom
winds up stealing Wanda's reality
warping abilities armed with some of the
most incredible Powers he's ever wielded
Doom attempts to force the X-Men and the
Avengers to join him in his quest for
ultimate domination as you might expect
the two groups can't reach an agreement
and the Avengers find themselves engaged
in battle with a supercharged Dr Doom
stature attempts to take on Doom
directly and Avengers Children's Crusade
number eight but it's far from a fair
fight he ends up killing her on the spot
though her father seeks revenge it is
Doom himself who returns Cassie to life
a subsequent story in the pages of
Avengers world number 16 sees several
major Marvel foes turn good and Dr Doom
hopes to write his previous wrongs Chief
among them is the death of stature which
he chooses to be the one and only action
he reverses thanks to the help of
Scarlet Witch's power
Stinger isn't the only variant of
stature we've seen in a parallel world
there's also the Cassie of the Ultimate
Universe Earth 1610 while originally
launched to be a more realistic version
of the mainline Marvel Universe ultimate
also got increasingly wacky over time
when they brought in Scott Lang for
example he was introduced as part of an
entire team of giant men and Cassie was
a member of their giant woman Brigade
appearing first in Ultimate Comics
ultimates number 17 in 2012. this
version of Cassie joins up with Shield
alongside her father she has quite a few
Adventures of her own though she was
once mind controlled by Thor's
villainous son modai and she eventually
joins a new ultimates team that took on
the appropriately named dark ultimates
if you're looking for the weirdest
version of Cassie Lang in the Marvel
Multiverse sit down and listen to this
tale specifically Marvel fairy tales
written by CB sabolski the short series
introduced readers to marvelized
versions of famous stories in folklore
in Avengers fairy tales number four from
2008 we find Marvel characters
populating a retelling of The Wizard of
Oz while Avengers fairy tales number one
explores the world of Peter Pan there's
also Avengers fairy tales number three a
retelling of Alice in Wonderland that
stars none other than Cassie Lang in
this version of the Lewis Carroll tale
illustrated by Takeshi miyazawa Cassie
takes the role of Alice while the other
members of The Young Avengers team of
that era play various roles in the story
it begins with stature's shrinking
ability sending her tumbling into the
same kind of rabbit hole as in the
original book bringing her to Wonderland
there she finds Patriot and Hawkeye
taking on the roles of the king and
queen team while Tigra is the Cheshire
Cat Wiccan is the March hair and
hulkling is the Mad Hatter even Scott
Lang pops up as the caterpillar in what
is easily one of the weirdest takes on
the Marvel heroes you'll ever see